[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yes yes yes the good guys are back
we're back the good guys are back we're
freaking back brother we are in our
nuclear bunker
fallout did the you know doomsday clock
is like down
yeah like you know doomsday's upon us
we're trapped inside we're we almost got
apprehended by uh dark brandon brown and
his and his uh loyal
his loyal storm troopers came into the
compound we almost got locked up in a
fema facility for speaking truth to
power folks but guess what we're here
we're live we're alive
and and we're gonna we're never gonna
stop
um it looks like we're right next to uh
black mesa half-life compound which i
like yeah you know yeah exactly they got
some head crabs out there
welcome everybody this is leftovers
episode 20. okay god damn it's been 20
episodes yes it has been sponsored by
babel thank you to them now uh first at
the top of the show we've got a lot of
good things to discuss oh yeah uh
hassan's birthday was recently we have
presents and festivities for you wait
really yeah yeah damn hell lina can you
bring out the shirts let's start there
because that benefits me
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah so you can play the music yeah you
play the music deck i like that
yeah here is three two three xl shirts
thank you the new teddy fresh drop
[Music]
these are my all-timers
fir uh you got the uh jeff bezos is it
has a small
penis it's true i think it's got to be
right and here yeah here it is out of
all the out of all the billionaires i
think he's the hottest one like with his
body after seeing elon musk's like body
i feel like jeffrey bezos has done a
better job
as like a you're like in the you know
more about bodybuilding than me
someone said that's he's on like
human growth hormone and that's what
makes him look like that uh i believe it
yeah i think i i wouldn't be surprised
if he's doing a little bit of hgh but
heh now i feel like is a lot more
commonplace than it used to be like
maybe in the 90s well why does he take
it i don't think he what do you mean
look at his no no no basil
i get it oh yes but it looks like it
looks like elon takes the human growth
hormone but doesn't exercise and then he
ends up
show me that side profile of elon
this one is what this one is elon musk
is a piece of [ __ ] yeah i like that one
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i like it um
and you can buy those of course at
teddyfish.com the new collection just
dropped uh thank you thank you
get your hands on these bad boys
can you show me elon musk's uh
yeah freak chest please
i'll stop you should have done that as
the merch
well this barrel chest we designed this
like uh six months ago but i think that
would be a good
addition to the series before you found
out about his is
before he found out about the little
elon that hides in his chest and
controls his body
oh i've never seen oh that's perfect
dude what the [ __ ] that's so perfect
whose body looks like that though yeah
we're body shaming it's so it's so
messed up except like i'm in favor of
body shaming billionaires yeah
especially because like
a big part of
uh
jeff nipper did uh did a video about
obesity is obesity of choice
really wonderful video
um and obviously there's so many
different factors that go into like
you know uh being overweight but like
elon musk on the other hand is like a
billionaire but he's not even overweight
it's like there's just some weird body
modification going on there yeah yeah
someone said he does human growth
hormone but he doesn't do the working
out part is that possible or is that
just a joke
i don't know he does have bubble gut
which is interesting because that is
something that you see in people like
joe rogan who do take like hgh or
aggressive amounts of steroids like
it's wild it i don't know i don't know
why he's like in the body like his
organs seem very inflated like his
organs seem like they're bursting out
yeah but anyway shout out to that dog
but it is a medical condition i believe
uh barrel chestedness is a medical
condition i think when your ribcage is
like expansive
but it doesn't look like that it doesn't
just look like that it looks like
something more so can we do um
can we find a picture of elon from
before he was the richest man in the
world and let's see if he's
if his gut is still protruding like that
because i want to know
is this the result of some
money made you like human
experimentation yeah yeah
i don't know if there's any shirtless
pics of him like 10 years ago i don't
think that there is but i mean well
don't be too sure
[Music]
you never know what's on google
well here's elon 2010
he was kind of he looked alright
yeah he looked decent fairly normal
i mean his hairline was was disastrous
during the paypal days and like he
recovered pretty yes pretty aggressively
from that you got such a good hair
transplant yeah probably maybe get a
full yeah i mean that his body looks
normal
that guy doesn't look barrel chested i
think he's been doing some hormone
experimentation on himself yeah that's
weird what the [ __ ] you're right yeah
this is rather strange
what you are what you are showing us
right now is rather odd because you do
not see any sort of deformities
no
at all maybe he's like hiding it
under his blazer or something i don't
know what's going on but anyway shout
out elon of course and anyway if you
teddyfresh.com i don't know if you i
can't see what they see right now but
there's all kinds of cool stuff here so
thank you and then uh hassan's uh
so let's celebrate hassan's birthday
here i got you a 2xl hat tell me oh
thank you
so originally
originally i wore his hat but it was too
small so i had this i don't know it was
too big
give me your hat right now
see this is perfect this is perfect size
yeah
hassan wanted me to know
that this
this
bucket hat was too small for his head
yeah and and why is it you wanted me to
say that for the world because everybody
says i have a small head and it's a lie
and we're here to address the lies folks
well proportionate to your body
yeah you have the body of a [ __ ] ogre
that's true i do have a i know i know i
mean i have a i have a very wide frame
speaking of elon musk's wide frame i
have a very wide frame myself so that
tends to make my head look small even
though it's not
well we'll have to do some measurements
you ever done a head measurement you
want to do i mean you want to do skull
measurements we could set that up for
for next week if you're comfortable with
that
let's do phrenology on the teddy some
phonology let's do phrenology on the on
the html
guys full blown let's make notes for
next week we're going to measure
hassan's dome okay
and then of course i have um
a birthday present for you more birthday
but what is going on
god this is something that is very
special
something that's very rare and so
and something that's very expensive yeah
go ahead and open it oh god what is okay
where's the link
i'll put the link at the top baby please
[Music]
oh here it is thank you
yeah you're gonna love this it is very
special
um
and i really got an amazon package in
here okay i think you're gonna love it
an unopened amazon package
oh
no
yes we did
look at that thing man
yes check it out
do you know the lore of this
pride
pride used to be a sin damn it
and then i made my own bust alongside
right that what is that alongside
world renowned philosophers
as though this is not a prideful moment
chopin
no napoleon an artist okay whatever and
leaders
but so do you know the lore of this that
some artist
is making busts of these great people
this is incredible dude thank you this
is uh yeah absolutely and i mean it's
500 bucks so just to let you know we
drop we went big time ethan's like
that's coming off here i just want you
to know
i just want to let you know dude
we work hard over here
man the barricades yes well we work hard
and thanks to our sponsors and babble
like babel yes sir
there you go
um so there you have it happy birthday
hassan
[Music]
thank you this is wonderful oh my god
this is gonna look this is gonna look
great doesn't he look a little touch
like birth defect
in that
just a touch he's got his eyes are
suspiciously close to one another yeah i
wanna hurt someone's feelings
my grandmother's pubic hair
i'm sorry wait wait why is the camera on
me where would we be without men give me
a kiss a son you [ __ ] man you uh
mimbo
yeah it's it's great he's like looking
at you so disapprovingly which is kind
of funny
i love this i [ __ ] love this so much
this is great good man i'm glad
very glad you liked it
uh he's one of the great man of all time
so
i let her have her way i let her have
her way
um well lots of good stuff happened to
talk about uh first let me give a shout
out big brother is happening do you
watch that
uh no
yeah i can't say i watch it either but
oh yeah but i did see something about oh
yeah i know you're gonna give a shout
out to let's take a look the thing is
now we have someone to root for
trooper nation
there are two two big brother uh
contestants who are fans so we got a
route for them to win
uh taylor turner
taylor telling turner how the most
online person she keeps up with his
hassan [ __ ] they then talk about him
well they mention me too so i don't know
why yeah they don't know somehow yeah
you got shafted on that one a little bit
why'd i get iced out of this uh chem
what the [ __ ]
block block them
anyway here's the clip
yeah excuse me
uh a little recognition would be nice in
the tweet
yeah it's messed up oh it's not you
gotta cook there it's not right that's
right
you know who
oh
it's called leftover oh my god it's
called leftovers funny
it's yeah
right now
yeah it's a really good political
podcast thanks bro um it's just a
like you know left if you know whoever
i'm following us off yeah wait you know
she doesn't know the [ __ ]
oh so i'm pickered
yes i do dude he's do you ever watch his
twitch stream yes i do
oh my god you got hassan heads on a big
brother i like him oh yeah i usually
catch him in the middle yeah it came
from me so hard to like plan when to
watch the twitch trip anyway that's it
so we're we're now rooting for
that makes me happy yeah that's great
that's cool love that there's so many
there's so many uh foot soldiers so many
football troopers uh in even in
twitchcon eu when i was in amsterdam oh
yeah yeah hello people came up to me
were like oh my god like leftovers
you're with the you know you do podcast
with ethan yeah there's there's a lot of
people love that love all you guys man i
don't like really leave the house that
much so
i don't get as much as that on in in
real life interactions yeah it's nice to
hear that they're out there
mr [ __ ] is one yeah you know who else
doesn't do that but when they do it
blows up jenna marbles dude jenna
marbles literally just got took a photo
with somebody it was like news did you
guys see that yeah
i love jenna though she got dirty she
done dirty she didn't i mean like
internet like that she
yeah but also like
it's wild that
i don't know i have a lot of thoughts on
this i like her a lot as well i love i
love julian um
i think he's a wonderful sweet kind
person and so is uh jenna from what i
understand i don't really know her that
well she is but
um when i saw that like she
self-cancelled kind of for her like old
videos and the way that people were like
popping off on her
it just
it just frustrated me so much because
like
only
we have a tendency often to only punish
people who care right because like
cancellation isn't real so
it's not a real thing so you only punish
people who have already like made amends
and have tried to better themselves
and we're so vicious to people who
listen because at a certain point it
moves beyond
genuinely trying to make progress or
change and it just becomes like oh how
can i move the needle in any meaningful
capacity oh well i can do that by
criticizing someone who i know has like
empathetic uh points of view to my my
plight my marginalization you're so
right about the only the people that
care yeah get cancelled and that that
frustrates the [ __ ] out of me i mean
jenna
she did some insensitive things a long
time ago or maybe you could say outright
uh uh offensive or racist i don't know
but that [ __ ] was like so long ago and
you know
obviously not like that yeah she knew
almost like that's the point if you do
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] like that shouldn't
that shouldn't carry over for the rest
of your life like we just do not have a
tendency towards rehabilitation and
growth when as human beings on an
individual level
we have loved ones that have problematic
opinions way worse than anything yeah i
mean and we understand we want them to
get better right so why don't you extend
that kind of empathy and love and
understanding to every single person
that you possibly can
it's something that i advocate for all
the time it's very frustrating and i
think it ties to america's like
incredibly draconian attitude towards
crime and punishment you do a crime
you're a criminal for the rest of your
life that should stay with you forever
you should go to jail for 30 [ __ ]
years for like selling weed yeah
and and it just sucks and this is like
like a microcosm of that kind of
hostility towards people who have done
uh things that are wrong i think
everyone has the capacity to
rehabilitate and i certainly think that
like content creators that have you know
tried to be funny and have done it in
like really hacky ways uh you know
especially if they make amends for it if
they recognize that that was wrong i was
talking about this yesterday you know
we've all we've all all of us who are on
the internet we've all done things that
are stupid that said and done things
that suck you know it's like you we
can't hold it over each other's heads
forever and there's a difference between
real crimes people who are actually
doing [ __ ] harm to this world and to
society who are actually just [ __ ]
like
pieces of [ __ ] psychopaths and then
there's people like general marbles who
literally just made some tacky jokes 10
plus years ago and it's just [ __ ]
outrageous by the way here's the picture
yeah i love that 100 thousand julian
looking [ __ ] jacked dude god damn it
yeah he's so sexy yeah he works out eh
he does
all tatted it up look at those legs look
at those goddamn legs i can't i'm not
that good leg is that good legs i mean
look at his quads dude those things are
busting he he [ __ ]
i don't know maybe hecker is mad
he's just he's just sexy man he's a sexy
guy he's got the tactical he's got the
tactical keychain too what's going on
yeah he's ready he's ready he's ready
he's ready to run dude he's got the
simply nail logical nail collection
collaboration that he did on the on the
fingies
look he looks like he's in a he's in a
shopping mall clearly and you know those
have have lately been a great place to
shoot up uh people have been enjoying
doing that and you got to be ready to go
no yes you know he's ready to go [ __ ]
go dude and jenna she's out there casual
but he's ready he's ready for business
yeah you got to be ready in america you
got to wear sneakers all the time you
know yeah because you never know where
you're gonna have to run for your life
in it
yeah it sucks she left but you know
there it is we got to stop guys we got
to be better i'm saying like there's
people like james charles
who and worse even but
he's like a serial predator incapable of
reforming his behavior
and this is someone who should be
cancelled like completely in order in
order for someone to be able to in order
for someone to be able to like reform
their behavior
i think uh one of the things they they
have to do is at least like see
that their actions are wrong and like
face some consequences if you can avoid
consequences for your actions then like
it's going to be highly unlikely that
you reform your behavior so when i say
like i believe in rehabilitation i don't
mean like no no punishment you know what
i mean no punishment whatsoever
i just mean that you know we should be
more considerate to people who have made
change in their lives
um but you were mentioning like even
people who break the law who do crimes
like i i think even they have the
capacity to well there's there's some
crimes that are too horrific i
personally am super opposed to the death
penalty it's so [ __ ] barbaric dude
yeah that the the state is killing
people and you know we've seen
throughout history that so many innocent
people are actually put on death row
even one is enough to justify throwing
it out but it's happened so many times
now and the fact that people still uh
support the death penalty
is pretty
freaky
um so i i agree that that uh uh
criminals can be reformed and uh but
at the end of the day no john hinckley's
greatest crime was that he he missed
well he didn't miss but he used a 22 and
it wasn't enough oh yeah speaking of
which i mean here's a reformed criminal
uh speaking of which this is the great
john hinckley the guy who shot ronald
reagan shut the [ __ ] out
john hinckley's out guys and he's based
as [ __ ] he said i believe in peace love
equity lbgt
lgbtq rights abortion rights animal
rights race mixing i was like well you
didn't raise money to raise money he's
been in jail too long yeah exactly
he doesn't know he doesn't know what the
proper terminology is but shout out
miscegenation i'm for it
uh that's great assault weapon ban
sharing the wealth green new deal black
lives matter prison reform and good old
rock and roll baby join the john
hinckley community my man yeah i am i'm
in
quarter pounder by the bigger video like
john hinckley went woke
go broke
no it's just like
like i said i have no problems with john
hinckley the only issue i have is that
he used the 22 and also uh you know
wasn't able to get the job done you know
what i'm saying if jody foster is giving
you messages through you know taxi or
whatever you gotta you gotta complete it
so what was the story with him he was
getting he was he was i think he was
like schizophrenic maybe right or i
don't know he was well and yes he
thought uh jody foster was uh
giving him secret messages to instruct
him to kill the people have we
questioned jodie foster about this i
mean i believe she was questioned about
it everybody was like mad at her they're
like jody are you talking through the
television to john hinckley have you i
think later later down the line there's
a video of of her even saying like i
think it's kind of cool oh no hell
enough yeah
uh if i'm not mistaken i think she said
something like that which it i mean it
is it is cool i mean [ __ ] [ __ ] ronald
reagan it's kind of crazy that this
guy's got swag for trying to kill ronald
reagan though it's like kind of wild in
it
for a while it's a little wild if i say
more if i say more i will get in trouble
but also you got he wasn't trying to
kill ronald reagan because he's like oh
this guy's gonna [ __ ] uh ruin
or he's you know he's gonna ruin america
he's like jody foster told me to kill
him too yeah it wasn't like an
ideological reason but it never happens
like that anymore you know what i mean
like
and and throughout time usually when
those assassinations happen like even in
japan like in the 60s i believe it was
like it was like a fascist killing a
communist leader you know what i mean on
television with the katana so even
ideological killings often times
surprise surprise is usually fascist
killing socialist leaders or communist
leaders
um assassinations often go that way yeah
but when you think about like shinzo abe
it was because of his like relationship
with the with the you know unified the
moonies
uh and and how like the assassins mom
lost
uh these as a mom like lost all of her
money because they they dump like
hundreds of thousands of dollars in this
[ __ ] cult
the cia created by the way the korean
cia alongside the cia created the
moonies
do you research people they're looking
no i mean it's not even a conspiracy no
it's like
that's just one to one straight up blow
back
um oops
so we could show the headline again
the jody foster thing that was a joke
that was a
website oh it was it was a hard times
website i'm a boomer yeah i didn't look
at the url
i thought it was plausible she's like
this is kind of dope like she retweets
it maybe it is kind of cool
anyway shout out to jenna and uh
and uh julian uh hope they're doing well
she's probably loving life though not
being on youtube not being a [ __ ]
influencer she's probably so happy
um yeah i i i don't i'm different i'm
buildibly
i can't do that
so let's get to the um
the topic at hand now we haven't talked
about this together yeah is that
uh hassan hopped on a call
with
cobra tate the human trafficker i like
to call him that so people it's like i
don't wanna they want the word
association yeah
and you take the human trafficker
did you watch his music videos by the
way i watched some of it they're so bad
that like it gave me psychic damage i
think like my audience was like please
stop like you are you're ruining us yeah
no it's incredible i think it's maybe
the worst music i've ever heard which is
you know saying a lot
but uh you jumped on a stream with him
and you absolutely eviscerated him so
satisfying to watch yeah and you know
i've been saying for a while that i'm
kind of
anti-platf anyone platforming tate but i
think you did uh obviously uh well the
way i incredible job because this is
something i've talked about you know
like we've had these sorts of
considerations in the past as well
um
the the thing i'll say is like there's a
difference between platforming someone
and and addressing their comments and
debating them
and and offering pushback
towards their messaging especially after
they've been thoroughly platformed
andrew tate is all over the place uh
there's a little bit of astro turfing
going on most likely with respect to
like how much he's popped off there's
also a multi-level marketing scheme that
he has called hustlers university that
creates a financial incentive for a lot
of people to make his videos to put his
videos out there to blast them all over
the place
um and he purposely says like
misogynistic controversial things in an
effort to get people who are like on his
side or who agree with that kind of
reaction or perspective to to you know
uh
like him but i i i think it's like uh a
mess just to focus on the multi-level
marketing i mean this man oh there's
more runs a [ __ ] human trafficking
operation in his building like
he was just [ __ ] raided
by the police because they got tipped
off that he was holding women against
their will by the u.s embassy i mean
what the [ __ ] dude what what am i
missing there's a lot of there are a lot
of uh
shady parts shady components to
andrew tate's business strategies
um i think that uh part of that
part of the shadiness comes from the
original like yeah he he had like 75
girls
in a webcam business where he literally
openly stays to like groom them you know
what i mean he was like these are girls
that never worked in this industry
a lot of swerves get mad at me and they
say like oh do you know you are a
promoter of sex work you you you believe
that like sex work right they're
trafficking yeah there is a there there
is a there is an unethical component to
sex work and this is the this is the
quote pull up the call he this used to
be on his
uh
courses website he openly says
my job is to meet women get them to fall
in love with me
and then to the point where they're
willing to do anything for me yeah get
them to do a webcam they pay me all
their money
and um
most of these women have never done
webcam or ever wanted to do webcam
yeah well and that that's just his
version of events like i said he got
raided by a [ __ ] the us embassy yeah
that one was uh that one was not for the
webcaming though that one was a was a
girl that was staying at his compound i
believe and then
he blames it on a angry boyfriend
because his girlfriend wanted to like
come to his house and like hang out with
them but
no i don't think that that's you know
yeah
but he openly has also talked about like
you know having dealings with the
romanian police he's openly talked about
why he moved to romania to like uh can
continue his illicit dealings no he said
he has ties to the romanian mafia as
he's mentioned
i moved to romania because their rape
laws are more lacks
it's not even just that he also says
that like all world governments are
corrupt which is true he's right about
that
but then when i say that i'm like we
should end that corruption he's like no
all world governments are corrupt so go
to a country where you can you know be a
brokey and not a [ __ ] billionaire and
still be able to engage in the
corruption yourself right he wants to he
wants the ball on a budget he wants to
be corrupt on a budget that's why he
moved to romania
he's pearl he's pro uh uh pro
corruption he says why am i an expert on
all male female interactions i've been
running a webcam studio for nearly a
decade i've had over 75 girls work for
me and my business model is different
than 99 of webcam studio owners yeah
they do it by consent i forced them into
it over 50 i groomed them
yeah nice dude over 50 of my employees
were actually my girlfriends at the time
and of all my girlfriends none were in
the adult entertainment industry before
they met me it's great wonderful
literally that was my job my job was to
meet a girl go on a few dates sleep with
her test if she's quality get her to
fall in love with me
to where she'd do anything i say and
then get her on a webcam so we could
become rich together pretty sure that's
illegal like what is this literally the
plot of taken yeah
where's where's liam nees neeson when
you need his ass bro
every time we've looked at this uh
archive of his website i never noticed
he's teaching them chess
but their name perfect chess attire
so here this is called the sicilian open
girls yeah the world would be a much
different place if his dad was like a
little bit more in his life i think for
for him at least
oh right his dad was a chess master yeah
yeah not about that okay
if he never there's the tie-in if you
never move the [ __ ] luton
yeah that's that's right folks don't
don't move to england
stay in indiana is she wearing a coney
shirt like connie
yeah yeah joseph connie 2012 he's all
about he's cut
is that weird i mean i mean he's having
a disconnect here yeah he's he's auntie
baby he's kind of it's
maybe he wasn't like maybe he was like
pro conan yeah
i mean he's like well it doesn't say
anything else it just says pony so maybe
yeah cody was balling on a budget he
drinks he's arseless university guy
right
america uses child uh uh
you know child military right why can't
they why can't coney do it in nigeria
but those kids those kids are don't have
[ __ ] yeah
they don't have a chance and they're
getting and they're learning valuable
skills become warriors right
he's top g he drinks bubble water yeah i
mean if the these kids are not going to
be men unless they drink the blood of
their enemies yeah
which is rumored to be what he does he's
actually a cannibal coney shut the [ __ ]
up
um i mean that's yeah
all right yeah and
that happens i don't think they drink
bubble water in the jungle though just
saying yeah no bubble water only
government water
they get their water out of a [ __ ]
well
yeah andrew tate anyway listen you guys
go on this debate
i think everyone's seen the clip by now
but uh
you just absolutely destroy him he's
talking about women drivers
and how
uh their work they're just worse because
he says so
and you know you guys should watch the
clip if you haven't seen it but it was
just so glorious yeah and and the boys
like
you know the boys were kind of riding
him pretty hard yeah
they were they were all about it yeah
they were like oh man you're just like
[ __ ] up the vibes right now i mean he
just like basically ran away i i think
like after he kind of owned the previous
dude before me who's like god he's like
a fortnight guy i think um
and he had like pink hair and stuff so
it was like a typical like sjw owned
compilation moment for him so he's like
riding off that high and then i come in
and i'm like nope
uh
and and he was not expecting that so
then immediately the vibes shifted
you know
it was so you're boring you're boring
you're boring you're ruining the stream
he even hit him out of here he even said
chill out
yo bro you're ruining the stream and
then i don't know who these guys are but
yeah they were dick riding so [ __ ]
hard dude yeah and the minute you logged
off he's like 17. like claims he's like
17 he's like a fortnight kid i don't
know what the [ __ ] going on
let me see if we can get capture the
moment where andrew runs off like a
[ __ ] just just just chill out like
there it is chill out man
just chill out
yeah
so what's up is it is it a little bit
more difficult when i'm not like uh the
traditional like sjw looking person is
that why it it feels like the stream is
a little bit more ruined no it's not
difficult as a professional i'll tell
you the conversation we just had yeah
you dude you've been kicked in the face
and stuff like i'm sure you can handle a
little of me
exactly so i'll tell you that's a
professional conversation we just had i
said i am biased and i don't believe
women can drive that's my personal
experience i don't care if anyone agrees
you came along and you came don't
interrupt me you came along and said
that's not true because of the evidence
i came and said i don't care about the
evidence my personal experience you said
i also have personal experiences and
we're all biased i agreed then you said
even if i had personal experiences that
said x i would ignore them because the
internet told me to believe why i
believe what i'm doing that's not what i
said
i said that i love that
women drivers getting in less accidents
empirically is an is internet uh drama
internet yeah no i mean but like
i brought this up before but
i think he knows better i don't think
andrew tate is a dumb guy i think he's a
very smart guy he just knows like that
his audience like the people that he's
trying to sell hustlers university to
are not people who [ __ ] care about
empirical evidence as a matter of fact
they're going to be people who are like
oh based you're based you're like your
personal anecdotes are more important
than like
evidence like covet because he's like
he's like a kova denier too a little bit
yeah like he tried to bring that up as
bait but i didn't i didn't like you know
i didn't want to talk about that i
wanted to just like hyper focus on one
element which is like the importance of
science which i think i did a decent job
of uh you know
showing why he was being silly what the
world is not flat analogy and he
believes in empirical evidence everybody
does they you know it's just a bad faith
they're just [ __ ] trolls man they
don't believe in anything except making
money and and like i said his audience
he's looking for dumb people okay he's
looking for dumb people to prey on he's
looking for the weak and the vulnerable
and the insecure men that's why when he
uh does this like hyper masculine [ __ ]
it works so well okay because only we
can insecure rudderless men who have
been left behind by society
go towards something like that and see
someone as transparently
overcompensating for their insecurities
like andrew tate as a beacon of
masculinity yeah that's it yeah exactly
if you have to say it you don't have it
anyone who says they're an alpha male is
not one okay anyone who says their high
value male is not one
he's just oozing insecurity and i guess
yeah i mean if you're a young man maybe
you don't see that and you think it's
cool i mean he's like the high school
version [ __ ] that middle school version
of what a cool person is you know what i
mean
uh yeah but those kids have credit cards
you know mommy mommy's credit card
grandma ain't gonna [ __ ] notice 50 a
month those kids have credit cards they
are gonna get uh caught up in a in
crypto schemes easily which he does as
well so
you know makes sense he's tailoring his
messaging towards the audience that he
wants to cultivate and he's doing a
great job he says in this uh
conversation he has over a hundred
thousand
he does
he does have a hundred thousand people
in the discord server oh in the discord
and that's only accessible if you're a
member yeah and that's you gotta pay
fifty dollars a month for it let's
[ __ ] go brandon yeah
love that
i do think he's gonna end up in jail
though one way or the other i think i
no
i guess if long no think about think
about like when you're doing
international cons when you're doing
international cons it's like very
difficult to capture you interpol is
like really bad at that [ __ ]
um if he ever more likely he gets
whacked by the romanian yeah for
crossing them
yeah you're absolutely correct i think
like that is that that's the other flip
side of massive corruption
i think his narcissism will be his
downfall um his constant need to be in
front of the camera and be like the main
guy to put a face to all the operations
that are happening behind the scenes
right um you know uh openly talking
about his ownership on uh multiple
casinos in romania that are literally
working that are not even
uh you know successful financially
and keeping them open keeping them
running running exclusively to like uh
[ __ ] over other casinos in the
neighborhood like you can't do that
unless you got you know some big
financiers some some big backers and
casinos are a great way to launder money
obviously there's a lot of cash that uh
you know is is being traded in that on
the floor there so
you know that's
basic romanian mob [ __ ] i guess
yeah i don't believe the hustlers
university is as successful as he
presents it either there's a lot of
botting going on i think right now
there's all the hype i i think he's
gonna go the way of ty lopez in a year
everyone's going to forget about him his
stick's going to get old no people
aren't going to be signing up anymore i
mean look at tai lopez he's [ __ ] who
wants me to take their money he's
he's shilling radio shack tokens i mean
the man is [ __ ] gone dude
who wants to lose some money lopez
started this as well he did he
he blasted pre-roll ads yep he also
showcased like an extravagant lifestyle
that he like didn't really own at the
time but he
basically leaned into it with the
lamborghini
reading a book a day
and he was in front of everyone and he
became a meme and then other people like
started platforming him because like he
legitimately was like bringing uh you
know eyeballs to the table
you start off astro turf and it turns
into organic grassroots uh mobilization
here in my garage and then you you fail
for a while you just like try to milk
you try to farm as many like fools that
would be caught up in the mlm
because it's just it's not a real
educational program and people just get
to solution yeah you don't have a
consistent business strategy if your
goal ultimately is to find the next
sucker every time with your you you
don't have any product
yeah
uh let's see where this goes
regardless of my own personal
biases that i might have
evidence is still more important than my
personal biases i love how you keep
talking over him so [ __ ] awesome yeah
people were he got real mad about that
so good
when you got talking at once
and you've lost and it's boring
it's boring
is that what happens you just say i'm
boring and i lost and then you win is
that what it is
do a poll in the chat and if you want
let's pull these 17 year olds
that was the debate that was great that
was
that's so good
oh that was that was probable the debate
and by the way i wonder has he said
anything since this no so he's been
radio silent on you no he uh you're you
know you're gonna be his uh sam cedar
you're gonna haunt him
well well to be to give him credit he
did say he wanted to come back and talk
to me and leave it when it happens um
and i think that that would be wonderful
to do i would love to do that he's too
much of a coward he's beta
he's an inferior male let's just be
honest yeah the muscles don't mean [ __ ]
when you're a coward dude and that's
just what you are unless you come back
to the table yeah
so we'll see but there's some other
there's some other hungry clown sharks
that saw the blood in the water and
we're trying to i mean i remember i'm
getting on it you know what i mean like
the fresh and fit boys yeah they yeah of
course i still don't know who's fresh
and who's out of the two neither of them
are [ __ ] fresh yeah i figured it out
so fit
is this the bald one yeah because he's
and then fresh is the guy who's kind of
like doughy because like you know but
he's not french
no he's not at all if anything he's like
fresh it's like fit and uh
what's the nice word for it i keep going
to barbados
yeah
fresh is not
he's not all there i mean they're both
neurodivergent let's be honest they used
to be called neurodivergent
i mean there's look there there are
plenty of wonderful neurodivergent
people in my audience none of them are
[ __ ] rampant misogynist you know what
i mean so uh to clarify yeah he's not
making excuses for it um uh it's just
like they're just whack i don't know
they're it's the same
it's the same strategy there's a lot of
there's a lot of whack news out there
there's a lot of whack dudes out there
that are just like looking for anyone to
confirm their biases
right their preconceived notions of like
masculinity sexuality women how they
operate and you know it's it's a target
rich environment these guys will just
like traffic the same [ __ ] thoughts
over and over again launder the same
like
you know brain broken mentality over and
over again and you can make a living off
of it oh it's easy it's so easy but i
think it's you know it's just
i i do have hope that people grow out of
it eventually you know i grew out of it
you can too yeah they they'll they'll
grow up and and uh
and they get old as [ __ ]
um the thing is they're doing like
andrew tate
the poor man it's like dollar store
andrew tate so they're not really going
to go anywhere but here they are
challenging us [ __ ] announcement i'm
going to make right now
record scratch bro
hassan ethan h3 all you ass clowns over
there me and andrew tate i've spoken
with the big g
we are challenging you as clowns to
debate
[ __ ] person
okay
because tay was telling me that y'all
like to mute the
he's mics crying about that i don't know
you weren't even the moderator [ __ ]
boomer dude that's not i don't have any
control over that brother i was on a i
was on a call that was that was directed
by someone else
someone who was dick riding him too so i
don't know why they think i have any
power over them
so stupid bro that's funny i don't like
dude
but that like that's not a serious
challenge to debate when they're like
you have to come down to florida this
dude with kids who does a podcast four
days a week to my dumb ass [ __ ] show
that nobody watches or cares about i
don't know why these people always want
me to [ __ ] be in their presence like
tim pool and [ __ ] too tim does that yeah
you got it you got to come over here
hassan if you want to debate you have to
come over he's like [ __ ] you got
a zoom i've seen you on zoom before
let's do a zoom call i'm not trying to
be around you
like
i just don't get it like it's it's gonna
be in your pictures it's not a sincere
challenge that's why yeah and they want
to be able to say that uh he wouldn't he
wouldn't and then they're always like oh
we'll pay for your flight it's like bro
that's not
you know yeah oh thank you i really
didn't have enough money to to fly out
to miami yeah
we'll pay well i will pay for your uh
economy plus ticket and put you in the
best western i will cover your costs
first of all why would i bless you all
why would i bless you like that are you
my homie do i know you do i like what
you have to say to florida to meet my
[ __ ] homies in club i don't leave my
house no that's what i'm saying like
that's why would i give you that
blessing like you're going to have a
[ __ ] banger podcast 100k views you
know what i mean like 100k [ __ ]
debating why would i do that on your
street no come on mine then just you can
stream we could both stream they're
[ __ ] cowards dude yeah
it's just
like i've already proven through the dms
and everything else
you'll debate us i don't know i have no
idea what these videos are yeah he's
talking about me he he he's this man
we've been talking in the dms and we've
been saying non-stop for what it feels
like a year
zoom in any [ __ ] time you want and
we'll debate anytime and he keeps
dodging us he's ghosting us he's dodging
us and then he goes on his show and he
talks about how
how we're dodging them in the dms i mean
that's just not true yeah i messaged
them on sunday and i still haven't
received a response yet yeah cowards
i mean at this point i think it's like
probably uh
easier for them to just keep claiming
that we're dodging them or some [ __ ]
um that like works better for his
audience than like actually debating us
you know what i mean yeah but i'm down
like honestly fresher you know it's kind
of stupid to platform like these guys
are too dumb to even make an interesting
point at least andrew tate has has uh
achieved some
mainstream relevancy so there's some
value in
taking him down but fresh and fit
already down they're down bad they've
been down bad i'll even cover y'all
[ __ ] flights or whatever sometimes
it's expensive so generous get some
points on mx you're so nice martin all
right you get something you're going to
find i'm going to come here to miami we
could do it here y'all want to wear
masks because you guys are scared of
covered fantastic and by the way you're
scared of covered you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you want to wear a mask that's fine i'll
allow it in our office i mean that's
right we usually don't allow masks
that's so weird but i'll make the
exception for you what an own bro
yeah yeah yeah
got another one bro i'll go there get
monkey pop or yeah [ __ ] kova you guys
have monkey pucks dude
come on daddy come here get some monkey
box man hold up coleman's here went off
to the side this is what he sounds like
it's my good side my daniel pretty [ __ ]
died like
if you guys want to do it
all right how about one state [ __ ]
excuse me six thousand miles apart yeah
and we just [ __ ] zoom yeah man
and we can do that now
yeah
so i mean they know they know how the
internet works because from what i
understand like i don't know how many
people watch their [ __ ] but like every
time they're live apparently they just
like pull up my broadcast and they're
just like they just have it in the
background
and i only know because like out of all
the 14 people that like watch them they
always somehow find their way into my
chat to be like ah they're talking about
you i'm like okay
so many people talk about me what do you
want me to do i can't address all of
them yeah especially ones that have 10
viewers i mean this is pointless i mean
i'm like i said uh
they're they're
i don't think they have enough impact uh
there was a time and place where they
were like way more prominent i think
maybe a couple months ago
but even then like i'll i'll i'll play
along i'll i'll i'll play with them like
a lion plays with his food
you know
[Laughter]
i just
it's fine like i don't have an issue
with it i'm just not gonna do it by like
flying to [ __ ] florida or whatever
that's not happening wait this from 16
hours ago maybe yeah i just found that
right now wait what the [ __ ] is this
are too scared to debate whatever dude i
love that that's what they do is they go
you have to fly in
to florida on who are by the way
christmas day by the way yeah two guys
who are way busier than me
my [ __ ] basically unemployed ass
well i mean or or you're too scared to
debate at least he's no longer a fed you
know what i mean that's like that is a
step up did we talk about that
he was a fed not only that but he worked
in the human trafficking department
yeah oh really yeah was he like one of
the the
does like one of the few parts of like
the entire dhs system structure that's
like actually adequate well actually the
only thing
is doing drug bust i've only seen him
with like uh you know he was a narc i
thought no he was in human trafficking
and was actually interesting about him
is he would go in the basement see the
girl locked up and say oh you're good
like that and leave so that's the
interesting thing
there's like this one right here
dhs that's not like completely [ __ ]
and actually uh was was you know trying
to combat you would think but he was
actually pro-human trafficking which is
interesting it's weird to be like a
hyper-misogynist and also simultaneously
uh
also simultaneously combat uh human
trafficking did you know about this
channel fed it
what he has a [ __ ]
oh this is why i got fired right he has
a pro cop uh commentary channel damn
that's that's cool as hell that's some
that's really cool yeah it's sick
love that
such a badass but yeah he actually got
called into cobra tate once and he just
dabbed him up and left so that's
interesting
yeah he was
he got called into an international uh
trafficking incident in romania and was
like all right boys pack it up this
one's good
[Laughter]
so uh anyway [ __ ] these idiots these
guys are all dumb asses uh oh we need to
do ad all right
brought to you by human trafficking nope
nope let's listen
well i mean it's a good lead-in isn't it
it's not it's like battle if you
literally
yeah they got mad
what did i say before it i think it
wasn't on this show but you you were
like uh speaking of abortion uh you
won't you won't be aborted
yeah jesus christ but it's true it's
good
as a fire segway it's valid
it's valid it was funny but yeah they
weren't thrilled about but what i'm
going for is okay so i can see this with
if you need to learn a second language
to rescue your daughter from trafficking
no mention of human trafficking but it's
an er selling point it is a good segue
but i don't i don't think we should do
that
just no no no illegal activity nothing
listen but they're not doing anything
illegal they're the heroes in this
situation because they have
they teach spanish french italian and
german is human trafficking big in any
of those countries human trafficking is
kind of big in every country i think
but let's not talk about that for
babbling nothing related to that
we'll do a buffer i'm begging you i'm
just you know letting my ideas uh you
know what i know you're spitballing you
know what ethan i just got back from the
netherlands okay i was in i was in
amsterdam beautiful city and the one
thing i was thinking is my my god if
only i could speak the made-up language
of dutch the made-up language it sounds
like a throaty german english mixture it
is very it's like basically
very close to german isn't that right
yeah but you know while everyone is
going out for summer travels whether
you're going abroad or why don't they
remember
and want to immerse yourself in the
culture you know what the greatest way
to do that is with baby babble
babble is the language learning app
babel is the language learning app that
sold more than 10 million subscriptions
10 million people learn a different
language with babel it's crazy wow thank
you babel and they do it with an
addictively fun and easy bite-sized
language lesson that they teach and
there's still time to learn a language
before you reach your destination to be
honest they have these great uh games
for as part of their lesson plan it is
very fun and addictive it's actually
super great i love their programs
um
i'm currently learning romanian for
obvious reasons no i'm just kidding they
don't have romanian and they're i don't
think they have it in their repertoire
oh miss yeah but french is there german
is there uh
[Music]
italian spanish italian come on did you
know that my son is seven percent
italian hey
that is weird in the lessons they're
like they're like you use your hands
like this
they don't do that
you know what's interesting in israel
this because in america if you do this
to someone it's kind of like up yours
right in america is it i thought this is
like uh delicious but
are you [ __ ] the one
isn't in america if you're like hey yeah
what does that mean in america if you
did that i don't know i'm doing a bad
impression of an italian person it is
italian you could go like this
chef's kiss yeah you know in israel
this has a very specific meaning what
does it mean wait a moment
and it's not rude or anything just give
me a second okay yeah i did not know
that
come on
give me so if you went to israel and did
this people would think you're saying
give me a minute yeah well there are so
many ways to learn with babel in
addition to lessons you can access
podcast games videos stories and even
live classes plus it comes with a 20 day
money back guarantee start your new
language learning journey today with
babble
uh i think you have to read the whole
body bro well i thought you were gonna
do the call to action i thought you were
gonna get in and be like right now save
up to 60 off your subscription when you
go to babel.com leftovers that's
babble.com
leftovers for up to 60 off your
subscription babble
language for life
wait did we have to read the whole
[ __ ] body though we didn't read the
body
that was a no quickly competent uh ad
read in my opinion oh god you guys well
let me read the body real fast okay
i'm telling you they're gonna say you
didn't read the [ __ ] body
read the body
with bobby only need 10 minutes to
complete a lesson so you could start
having a real life conversation in new
language as little as three weeks
clap
one clap i was taking my when i finished
a bullet point you did one clap well no
i gotta take this off first i'm getting
hot in here i'm getting hot thinking
about all the new languages i'm about to
learn mm-hmm
other language learning apps use ai for
the lesson plans but babel lessons were
created by over 150 language experts one
clap
their teaching methods have been
scientifically proven to be effective
one clap you're doing too much just one
okay in unison ready clap
okay
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian and german please clap
plus bible speech recognition technology
helps you improve your pronunciation and
accents clap
there are so many ways to learn with
babylon additional lessons you can
access podcast games video stories and
even live classes plus it comes with a
20-day money-back guarantee clap
start your new language learning journey
today
and i think you already did the call out
but right now yeah this is dude this is
good air time how what are they gonna be
mad about it's like a 20-minute ad
right now save up to 60 off your
subscription when you go to babel.com
slash leftovers that's bible.com
leftovers for up to 60 off your
subscription
babble it's language for
life which is
what hopefully andrew tate will be
serving in prison am i right life oh god
okay
unaffiliated with babel completely
come on that was a beautiful reads
who could be upset about that guys go
sign up for babble so then get mad at us
uh where were we we were talking about
the police club
uh we were talking about the the these
mourns want to debate us i'm over it
[ __ ] yeah but um
we were all we were gonna have a debate
about
friend of the show pewdiepie
pewdiepie getting canceled for making
fun of a deaf black woman who did sign
language on a tick tock well i don't
think is there a debate i thought we
were pretty much in agreeance or well
let's hear what you have to say i was
saying like it's good off camera i was
like it's so good i love that
but this so i i don't know if this is
even a story i i like i was going
through the comments
no twitter and i think it's like 90
people defending him like this is so
[ __ ] that's how it is all the time
he's like because he's his pewdiepie
right like he hasn't had a controversy
like this in a while because i feel like
he's just been off the yeah he's been
off the radar right but this is a in my
opinion see i don't know what your
opinion is now but i'm interested to
hear it i mean this is such a stretch i
mean come on get leave no i think he's
being i think he was being a a bully
like a dick right and
i think that we have a tendency to
immediately take something
and turn it into from like being a bully
and a dick to like oh well this is
ableist and racist and there might even
be like ablest and racist undertones in
uh people being a bully but like that is
oftentimes accidental um pewdiepie's
background is the reason why a lot of
people in these spaces don't give them
any sort of charitability and that's you
know somewhat understanding if that's
your opinion but like well let's watch
the clip so here's this uh tick tock
that
went viral i guess
so deaf women's signing is considered
tick-tock cringe and i know incels are
going to come to his defense like oh he
didn't know he has over 100 million
followers he should have learned by now
to do some [ __ ] research before
spewing [ __ ] so let's watch i've got
a drive through and it has like the
people where they stand outside and they
take your order before you go up to like
the window so i pull up and i roll my
window down and this lady
no i'm not listening to this
look she has your crazy nails man so
anyway what i did was i went outside and
then i peed and then i pooped a little
bit as well and it was crazy by the way
uh my big i don't like the tobiscus
vibes with the dog impression that was
my my biggest problem
oh my god i know that reference now i
learned about him i don't like it just
yeah he's i mean he's like also
culturally stuck in 2017 a little bit
obesity's called written house collab
yeah i did it was so whack um anyway
here i'm gonna wait wait before let me
finish the video i also do think that we
should show her response after okay let
me just i sent it in the discord okay
good my name is distracting her guys
let's see so in my opinion
it seems pretty obvious he's just
talking about the nail sound
i didn't even notice that she was uh
that she was deaf
i thought her voice sounded completely
normal so i didn't even notice
or know that she was deaf until i read
the caption so i i don't think that
he was he was referring to her nails i
mean clearly i i don't know anything
about i did not know anything about this
person um i i looked into it a little
bit and i think we should listen to what
she has to say all right because she
just seems like a wonderful person who's
like uh you know doing a little bit of
disability activism like you know
putting it putting
uh uh
you know
talking about even her nails as well as
a matter of fact let's just watch let's
just watch the whole video but it starts
off at
uh i'll tell you exactly when it starts
off because it starts up at 22 seconds
after the pewdiepie thing okay so here
just listen to what she has to do here i
can see here in the preview where it
starts
but
um i wonder what was the context of him
watching this uh he was doing a cringe
compilation
i don't get why that's cringe i feel
like she should ever have been included
in that yeah i mean whatever and i think
he forced a reaction right obviously of
course that's i mean half of that is
that for sure but whoever put that in
that compilation is [ __ ] there's
nothing cringe about her well there's
there's a
it's tick tock there's so much more
cringe than like a random deaf girl uh
you know using sign language with like
nails and stuff seen a guy with a thong
speedo with nipple [ __ ] cops sucking
his nipples or like 90 of the [ __ ]
little zoomers that are like
dancing
baby like i one of the things i see all
the time now is like
oh you got acne scars oh that [ __ ] turns
me on it's like bro you're 26 just
because you look like you're [ __ ] 17
doesn't mean that you can like do this
kind of like over yeah they'll do that
like oh your acne scars are so big a
role playing thing yeah i think they're
just like trying to you know tailor
their their message around
young 14 year old girls and [ __ ] that
are insecure about their bodies did you
brush your teeth recently damn girl
or like your stretch marks oh she's a 10
but she has stretch marks that means
she's an eleven girl
what that's out there i love that but
also like i don't have a problem with
the bodybuilding video i really like
your smart stinks i love that no i i
have stretch marks i i don't have a
problem with body positivity it's just
like that one is that is like so
carefully crafted for a specific
audience yeah yeah listen listen yes
let's see what she has to do can i just
real quick just for some extra context
um when i first watched this i thought
he was doing the voice that he does for
his dogs he always does in his videos
and i've seen a lot of people defending
him saying that as well
um i'm not completely familiar with the
situation but i just want to put that
out there what are people defending him
for oh people thought that she was like
making fun of her voice
no no he was doing like yeah cringe ass
hibiscus dog voice
i mean that was my big i i felt a little
bit icked when i watched it when i heard
the dog voice and that was my face i
thought it was like can i get one of
those four milligrams so i could ship my
fan i'm serious i need a kit you don't
need to [ __ ] your pants dude well don't
tell me what i needed not to do there
you go you live your life i'll live mine
he's a 10 but he shits
on the broadcast
yeah she's a he's a 10 but he doesn't
wipe thoroughly
all right well here let's watch what she
has to say
i've been blowing my phone up about this
so let's talk about it apparently
there's a big youtuber named like pewdie
whatever i don't know his name but
[ __ ] burn [ __ ] yeah beauty watch
whatever oh pewdiepie uh
true though huh
i mean he i i i don't mind that he like
went off the radar i think like that's
not a bad he still gets a lot of views
he just
he's not trying he's he's laying low
yeah
by the way he was she put her in a
cringe comp so she's perfectly in her
right just just call him ldpi if she
wants to
thank you
video to one of my tick tocks making fun
of like my nails making fun of my signs
with his dog and then like i guess at
one point mocking my voice so how do i
feel that's actually true now that i
think about it he was making fun of her
signing
yeah
which is something i didn't consider
when i first watched yeah he was
definitely making fun of her signing i
mean this like kind of dovetails in the
the kamal harris thing too where like
you know people are trying to be more
like uh
uh you know people are trying to make
more accommodations for uh you know
disabled people and that's like
perfectly valid i don't know why people
[ __ ] lose their minds
yeah what the [ __ ] stairs everywhere
[ __ ] i'm so sick of all these
crawl up the stairs [ __ ] i don't give a
[ __ ]
yeah you find a way up [ __ ] not my
problem yeah no more ramps we got to
start a political group again yeah
braille like or uh what is it no more
[ __ ] weird bumps on [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
that braille is out
it's it
makes me feel icky yeah it makes me
angry okay let's let's see what she says
i feel like it was very weird and very
unnecessary but at the same time i
wasn't surprised i'm used to it it's
been a big issue in the dust community
i've been trying to like normalize and
put it out that using nails while
signing is normal like it's okay but
then a big creator comes on here and
puts us like a million steps back so
it's very frustrating i feel like if any
other you know what she's making she's
spitting facts no exactly like i think i
i think she's like you know i don't know
anything about this person but like it
just seemed like she's like a normal you
know kind individual otherwise i'm sure
people will [ __ ] milkshake ducker
immediately be like oh you said
you said a racist thing about asian
people in 2014 when you were eight i
like to call that ken boning oh yeah
well that's a there's a good term for it
too but like it's just you know
otherwise it seems like she's doing a a
very specific thing
and
she knows the kinds of uh commentary
that she gets the kinds of criticisms
that she gets for it but here let's
let's i mean yeah based on i mean it's
pretty incredible that she
her language skills are incredible her
signing is good she's making content for
deaf people i mean it's awesome
just sick of ramps
yeah it's not her fault you stop it you
stop moving your hands like that it's
scaring me
you're throwing what are you doing are
you doing ninjutsu
the hell is that
by the way pewdiepie pinned a response
comment which we should read after this
person was telling this story but they
had long nails on but they didn't need a
sign to get their pointed call he would
have listened to the first story and
maybe even had a laugh but because i had
to sign to communicate and i had long
nails on he like stopped the video after
like two seconds didn't even listen to
the story and then after that [ __ ] to
like make fun of me signing with his dog
maybe he didn't know i was doing sign
language maybe he just didn't like my
long nails that's okay a lot of people
don't like them that's fine they're not
for you if that was the case you should
just be like oh i do not like her nails
and just skip the video but instead he
chose to watch the video stop it and was
like oh i know there's too much and then
he proceeded to like mock me doing sign
language which shows he knew i was doing
sign we also knew he knew because
there's so many people was calling him
out after he posted it he went back and
removed my clip he didn't remove it but
he put like a sound over it so you
couldn't see what he was saying about me
which i feel like made the situation
worse you really could have just like
addressing be like my bad i didn't know
she was signing i just didn't like the
nails and we really would have been fine
but no you decided to like go back edit
it out and sweep it under the rug like
nothing happened that's kind of fast
um i think like you're very you have uh
limited tools in your tuba in that
situation can't you like delete a part
of the video yeah you can click
completely i don't know why he just
covered it i thought he could i thought
he just like took it off to his response
he said he edited out the clip uh yeah i
guess we can just let me finish your
video yeah maybe maybe at the time like
there was a there was some
miscommunication there or something but
but i think she has a good point about
like
just deleting it versus actually saying
something but but like if you guys if
you delete it and you say like my bad uh
i'm sorry and then you move on like i'm
not gonna know what i mean like she has
a point because a lot of times when you
go back and remove it it does make it
worse for her because his rabid fans are
just gonna see him as the victim and her
he's the victim and she's the aggressor
luckily she is i think from what i
understand luckily she is well equipped
to deal with something like this one
because like she does disability
activism on the internet and you're
always going to get you know dunked on
for no reason and two she's like a
relatively sizable content creator on
tick tock i think she has like three
million or more [ __ ] uh you know tic
toc followers so what let's give her a
shout out what's her
not that she needs it from us but i'm
curious what's her um
i just uh scrubbed through his video
real quick just kind of looking for that
part i don't see it yeah he probably
clipped it out you have clipped it out
entirely yeah i don't yeah
i watched it okay
i see noel miller on the side says am i
out of touch the answer is yes
there you go this [ __ ] told me
you know you wanted me on the podcast
like eight months ago
no no wow you are out of touch no
calling out on the biggest platform
there is 12th podcast in the world right
exactly
you're in trouble yeah [ __ ] you're in
trouble that crypto [ __ ] yeah
anyway let's let this queen uh finish
popping off
baby it don't work like that over here
if you made a mistake it makes a mistake
you don't just get to like mock deaf
people who have already been struggling
for years with people like you and then
like go about your day like nothing
happened and then to top it off since my
video was so cringy so weird you
couldn't even watch it for more than two
seconds you went ahead and put in your
thumbnail i really try to give him like
the benefit of the doubt too like maybe
he really just doesn't know maybe he's
like
really unaware even though it's 2022 and
like there's deaf people in sign
language all over the media but the
mapping of like the sign and the voice
and then going back and editing it out
and then putting me on the thumbnail i
was like oh she was in the thumbnail do
you have the original thumbnail
that's important context too
you know
the thumbnail yeah the thumb yeah
i see both sides she makes a great point
about the signing that i honestly didn't
consider i don't think
i i i don't know we're back baby it's
2016 all over again you know people are
yelling at pewdiepie pewdiepie's doing
some [ __ ] that like
uh he didn't realize was [ __ ] up
that's it i i don't think he's trump's
running for president yeah 2016. it's so
good hell yeah dude i love it i think he
did this maliciously i just but but i do
think with that peop that we do need to
be more considerate about how we
are you just like about things if you're
going to be mean be mean to [ __ ] like
actual bad people don't be mean to
[ __ ] you know random
deaf girls on the [ __ ] internet you
know what i mean like
especially when they're not being like
even if you're like a random deaf girl
on the internet you could be a [ __ ]
total douchebag right but
in that circumstance like she's not yeah
she was in the thumbnail that's it so
that's that's that's my that's my take
on it like everybody likes being mean
every now and then you know what i mean
i'm a hater i say it all the time i hate
you i came out with a hater i came out
of the closet yesterday as a hater ass
[ __ ] yeah i'm a hater ass [ __ ] too i
wake up in the morning i'm hating i'm
waking up early to get a
extra two hours of hating to get done
you know what i mean right but like
direct your attention on people who
deserve it this is the new thumbnail
no
i think i think felix is just trying to
avoid any controversy at all costs and
he's probably like oh [ __ ] this yeah he
i don't think he meant for any of this
happening but you know she makes a good
point i mean he's doing great he he's
been doing great he's been doing great
avoiding controversies and again i don't
think felix has done anything that's
like warranting again we need to we need
to
measure our criticism i mean oh oh felix
has some old feelings has some
controversies i don't know i'm talking
about this in a specific situation okay
what he did here is
let's he doesn't need to be castrated
okay but you know what you want you want
to say something well there is a there's
two sides of this right where um there
is uh the type of behavior that
everybody engages in as soon as like
someone like him uh is is caught doing
something
um it is uh ramped up to the
maximum degree yeah where it's like oh
he's bad because he's already exhausted
charitability with a lot of people for
understandable reasons right i myself am
one of those people who's also exhausted
charitability with like the most
annoying [ __ ] factions on the
internet you know what i mean so every
time i get like
mired in controversy because i bought a
[ __ ] shirt that's expensive or bought
a house or bought a car or whatever the
[ __ ] everyone immediately brings back
old [ __ ] even if you've made amends for
it or even if the old [ __ ] isn't that
significant in
pewdiepie's circumstance he didn't
really do too much uh
as far as like a men's i mean he's
raised some money not for adl but the
other one uh he raised
money for like
you know uh kids in yemen which was nice
of him to do you're talking about the
the when he said the death toll jews uh
fiverr praying
there was so much i think that was i
think he like
he hyped up like a small channel uh that
was oh yeah
yeah straight up a [ __ ] nazi that was
really i didn't like that he platformed
ben shabibo either that was really
[ __ ] up too like i think he the way i
see it i think he much like many
uh
young white dudes on the internet got
caught up in that whole like alt-right
alt light you know right-wing
reactionary shtick on the internet um
and and got whipped up into that into
all of that and like lightly i might
make references to it that
people at the time are very upset about
one thing that upsets me about like the
pewdiepie community and i think this
probably affects a lot of people's
opinion about him
is that he becomes a lightning rod
for like really reactionary pieces of
[ __ ] on the internet yeah to rally
around him and turn it into their cause
and because felix never addresses things
and
sometimes he does right like on the
n-word thing he made a really heartfelt
apology
um but like he doesn't like in this case
he just erases it
i think it gives air to these really
extremist people that all of a sudden
become like oh we love pewdiepie i think
i think he did well let's see what his
apology was under the video all right
let's finish it let's finish let's
finish this and then see that yeah look
at that
you know but i mean we all live and
learn if you did not know before he
definitely knows now
hello everyone what the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
are you bro what is going on nothing to
do with this get the hell off my screen
no he's just that so let's go to the
original video i think this is the guy
that just like cut the video hold on i
actually want to hear what he says again
we'll come back with a new update about
bdy story
if germany released the new video
responded to watch out dramaalert
he's got a new game
yeah didn't even he doesn't even hide
his baldness under a hat right like
we can't do that why oh
there's been complaints to youtube
about well i'll say we don't we can't
make fun of his physical attributes i'll
just put it that way
we don't there's no problem with being
bald right right here
i'm about chaser what do you mean look
at that
favorite producer's bald bald
representation baby yeah let's go i'm a
ball chaser
you chase that bald i'm a ball chaser
yeah i i advocate for the bald but
because i fetishize them i can't say
anything okay i don't want to say
anything but let's just say
you want to come on a bald head
and like like a bab all balds are
beautiful that's right
do you sunscreen your dumbs that uh
again yeah of course yeah hey babe a
signed ball deferred assigned bald at
birth and all balls are beautiful
i agree all balls are beautiful except
for keemstar
but not because of the physical
attributes but because of the things he
says all the time i don't want to say
anything that will compromise
some intel or relationship i'll just say
that it's very [ __ ] i i'm in a very
ironic situation
right now
where uh
i shouldn't say it i'm gonna say
something i don't know how to put it in
a way that that that all right well
that's well let's get back i want to see
what pewdiepie had to say i want to i
want to see what he uh what his response
was well he can't we didn't i want to
see what he says
about this guy dude
this guy's going to be huge bro
you just want to plant a
you just want to plant a competitor to
keemstar i can't wait to start flaming
him on twitter for the record uh
scarlett may is the tick tock of the
person scarlett gourmet
oh i have dot one she has 6.2 million
followers i was wrong i thought she had
like three she has 6.2 million followers
okay
oh six point two holy first oh my god
she's she's killing it you know crazy
though that like she's like a huge
influencer so it's kind of crazy just to
throw her in there like some random
cringe
yeah i mean there's a lot of cringe-ass
[ __ ] huge influences i would say most
of them but i'm saying that she has some
notoriety i mean people know who she is
got such an operation he he's not
picking these videos you know what i
mean that he's like react i don't think
so i think he's like one thing i've
always one thing i've always respected
about him is that he has like a
bare-bones staff he's just like him and
his editor right he has two editors as
far as i know yeah no i love that i'm
the same and i and i i do actually like
that i mean it
creates issues
if your
you know moral compass is like thwarted
a little bit or like [ __ ] up and it's
out of whack as a consequence of like
you know watching a lot of the same
reactionary content that people in your
audience was watching in 2016 but
ultimately you you know i i like the way
that he has managed to
stay uh as a as a
you know
fluid but relatively small operation
right
i know that he's not making the
compilations
right people the people that are more
familiar with pewdiepie saying his
editor uh compiled this video that he
reacted to okay but you know so
here is uh one with eight million views
just to give her a one idea
i'm deaf not illiterate but they'd be
like well how can you speak i'm dead not
you and then they're like well how can
you drive like i'm deaf not blind damn
how do you do that
okay so she does like she does like a
bit which is good shout out scarlett may
on tick tock seems very cool
but anyway we didn't finish what he was
talking about
circulating
in on internet
people on social media supported here
and
criticized b2i and they demand him to
apologize to
to the girl uh he's got his own
controversy
he's got his own controversy what's
going on
i think it was just summarizing god we
gotta go down
subscribe to that channel keep tabs on
it i want to get all my drama from that
channel from now on and i'm not arab
nobody reports the news like him
okay let's read pewdiepie's comment
ready
here we go let's see let's see if it's a
good apology because i i have apologized
many many times over for my
controversies i've been canceled a lot
so this is a pinned comment on the video
it says hey just to clear a few things
up i edited out the clip with the girl
that has the long nails had no clue that
she was deaf but kind of dumb of me not
to realize still watching through the
clip i only poked fun at her long nails
the voice i did for my dog is the same
voice i've given the dog for years
and making my dog's paw move was poking
at people always dancing or doing some
move on tick tock which is an ongoing
theme in the whole video anyway honest
mistake my bad
i think it's valid yeah like i mean
that's that's a decent the way to i mean
it's not it's not our place to like
[ __ ] you know we're neither deaf nor
like
a young black girl on the internet or
anything you know
it's like
uh it's not our place to like take an
apology but as a as a a person
uh
in in these sorts of spaces i mean that
seems like that's the best what are you
gonna do i i believe him that uh he
didn't know she was deaf because i
watched it the first time through and i
didn't realize she was deaf and i didn't
even know realized she was doing hand
signs it's a very it's a very common
thing that happens like whenever i uh
whenever i'm uh like covering the news
or whatever whenever like joe biden
comes out there's always like a sign
language interpreter on the side
and like people always be like oh she's
popping off like you know what is she
doing like doing techno dances like it's
like a super common thing i think it
comes from it stems from a place of
ignorance which is ironic because like
that's exactly what scarlet may's entire
account is like dedicated to combating
which is like more visibility because in
a lot of instances it's just about
visibility for a lot of a lot of
disability a lot of disabilities on the
internet um and so that's funny that
this is how it unfolded but ultimately i
think it it served it an overall decent
purpose where she was able to clearly
communicate her position
and like
the thing is from the from the
perspective of like people who are out
of touch right the one thing you can
never be is cringe okay
um and
and
sometimes a lot of people who are uh
advocating passionately for their
existence people who are marginalized
understandably come across as emotional
and to people who are out of touch they
they only hyper focus on the aesthetics
and they will look at that and go oh
that's cringe she's being cringe she's
not
in this situation like she's very
clearly used to it not at all and and
you know
in a very adult way uh dealt with the
with the matter the fact that people are
calling that cringe is pretty sad enough
she is cringe at all no i'm saying the
fact the very fact that that video made
it into a cringe compilation in itself
is pretty sad and [ __ ] up
that being said you know
i totally get what she's saying she's
totally right but i and i believe
felix didn't know and there you have it
what do we think so who who who do we so
who dies if you're gonna
what i think is if you're gonna bully
uh somebody who's deaf
somebody who deserves it like helen
keller
i can't say anything about the subject
matter okay
all right that's true what is that what
is what is she flying towards i don't
know what that is rumored rumor has it
she was listening to hassan [ __ ] on
twitter oh my god okay all right
let's move away from this right now
what are y'all doing to me last words
work they deserve
no
okay just saying
no yeah all right let's move on nope yo
did you see this biting clip this shit's
kind of weird
oh googly eyed bited yeah this is kind
of [ __ ] wild
um
oh no i think he looks like a deep fake
like he put a like a
slightly only slightly younger brandon
as a deep fake in front of the regular
brand younger he looks more [ __ ] up
than ever yeah he's suited he's on that
he's on he's probably on some steroids
you know like they put him on the thing
to keep him going man they're not always
the kova they're doing like weekend at
bernie [ __ ] they got like some puppeteer
in the back of his coat holding his body
dark brandon is upon us i'm i'm fully
invested in dark brandon okay
he he he took out shinzo abe uh
he he he assassinated shinzo abe
he is he has
personally uh assassinated more trump
supporters than donald trump ever could
with kovid
okay
simultaneously fake
shinzo
neutralized gas prices were first high
by the way this is the dream this is the
future that we deserve that's right
arab news roe versus wade two
we support you dude
we support you my dude
hell yeah shout out
all right let's watch this it's just
weird as [ __ ]
you can't be pro-insurrection and
pro-cop you can't be pro-insurrection
and pro-democracy he's got that sex
direction and pro-american you know
what's funny what apostles again
um it's doing the face tracking [ __ ]
that you do on tick tocks too a little
bit in the beginning where it's like
and it's moving can't be pro looking
like bella porch
oh you're right yeah it can't be but how
did they put this way out this is so
insane what they put i was like well
hold on that's a fan edit and i was like
no it's from joe biden no dark brandon
should do bellaport style like the the
um
like the face
face
and his voice sounds super hoarse too
his voice sounds sexy dark brandon he's
hot it's an impersonator bro he's a
cadaver yeah no he's been cloned for
sure
his what's happening is he's a cadaver
he's dead his face is is not animated
it's a deep fake over his face
and someone's puppeteering his body no
no this is a clone this is one of the
dark brandon clones for sure like he
yeah they they they brought him they
brought him in they brought him in my my
speculation is that when he went to
saudi arabia he stole the orb okay i
remember the orb he stole the orb the
all-powerful
like national treasure style uh heist
yeah yeah he basically stole the
powerful orb and and took away mbs's
power okay okay that's why the gas
prices are low then look a weak man like
donald trump taken over by the orb
controlled by the orb completely
okay
yeah you can see like the orb is
controlling him
right dark brandon knew the curse was
upon him that he only had two yield
stole the orb oh yeah forward yeah
lowered gas prices immediately by
stealing the orb okay but he died so
then they had to clone him this is dark
brandon too
i'm fully on board with this theory yeah
dude so how many how many dark branding
clones are there think about it this way
more people have died uh from kovid
under brandon's uh administrator oh my
god a little a sneak peek for the next
uh video i mean he would pop off if he
did the face thing
you know what there's actually an update
i sent a link right now might help
clarify what was actually going on in
that video you can't be pro insurrection
oh
oh no this is this is very important you
need to pull this up
oh god arab world news covered it oh
dude hold on he's on it everybody back
up
how do we get the price down
well the new report today shows that
hello everyone welcome to my
the channel is never dropped with arab
world news
he's on it
this story is trending on social media
after abiding quote and appears to
speaks for at least one minute i feel
like he's coming from my job too now
by the way 78 views i like this video
i'm in your [ __ ] lane arab world news
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] dude you know
what bro
he's taking over and i stan arab world
brandon
i'm subscribing i'm liking i'm [ __ ]
stan oh god oh no
how are you fupa troopers already here
we are just talked about it there's six
minutes and four minutes ago y'all are
already on it that's crazy
normal human beings blankets their eyes
15 to 20 times
so
biden should blanket his eyes once two
three or
four
seconds in the last speech god damn it
turn it off this is really this is too
compelling commentary is too good he's
literally coming from though he actually
he's he's right not one can't be
pro-insurrection and pro-cop you can't
be pro right
you can't be pro-insurrection and
pro-american donald trump blocked the
courage to act little police brave women
i'm in the lab hold on can you turn up
arab world news his audio is so [ __ ]
low
yeah
she's trying to do a mashup
yeah again we have a new story about
fighting this [ __ ] can't be
pro-insurrection improvement
resurrection and pro-democracy
i don't even know what you're doing
right now
america
his eyes once two three or
four
second in the last speech
in the ending of the video support me by
like i'm looking for more uh you did do
that though you did support him by
liking i do support him he is the
[ __ ] future bro but like i said dark
brandon uh he's a clone stole the orb
got shinzo abe uh
assassinated
gas prices are low he's doing he's doing
uh he's raising the interest rates on
purpose as well right you know what i
mean it's all it's all trust the plan
trust the process show us the plan
no but in a serious way i am worried
about joe biden's health he's just so
[ __ ] i'm just
one of the things i've been talking
about and maybe i want to try discussing
with you is the gerontocracy going on in
this country i'm just so [ __ ] sick of
people
especially in government specifically
who are just too [ __ ] old to be
leading this country i'm just so tired
of it and you know listen joe biden
you're too [ __ ] old
it's not like
it's not like the leader at the helm has
to be all that competent like ronald
reagan i would like them to be
what about senators and members no no no
i i agree like 70 dude i agree i'm
saying it's it's it's ridiculous but
like it's basically a well-oiled machine
that runs on its own you know what i
mean like
it's not true in congress
i mean it's it's a part of the problem
what you're describing is a part of the
problem because like they don't have
they don't have any sort of like
ideological reasoning for the way that
they act that's why they allow lobbyists
to write the legislation for them um
and and that is a part of the problem if
you were if there were younger people
that were genuinely interested in doing
the the job that you're supposed to do
and advocate for the values and causes
that you claim you care about then yeah
we would have probably a little bit
different uh the outcomes could be a
little different but that's also not
going to happen without like any sort of
bullying mobilization any sort of
mechanism from the ground up because we
have no stroke dude i'm done with this
[ __ ] i'm done pretending like oh you
can't be ages i'm ageless when it
matters oh dude i'm able i
i look up to old people i respect them
but i'm not [ __ ] down with 40 of the
members of senate being between 60 and
69 years old 25 a whole quarter from 70
to 79 years old seven percent is 80 plus
and i can't get up
um
listen and then what really interests me
is that there's mandatory retirement
ages and lots of occupations even here
in america
you know usually you can't do that but
they make exceptions because it's such
an important [ __ ] job unlike members
of congress
you can't be like a commercial pilot i
have it here check it out mandatory
retirement age for a pilot 65. even
that's too high god damn
65 if you made 59 if you made it 65
you'd lose half of congress
yeah wow that's awesome true that's
insane you lose half of congress i mean
how many more than half i mean how many
65 year olds do you know that are more
than average
liquid technology we're living in a
technological world where
these tech companies need you need to
understand them you understand
technology they need to be if you want
to regulate them and make meaningful
change you need to understand
the world you're living in i mean i just
have my dad and jimmy lee on the show my
dad is pretty tech savvy for someone his
age
it took the both of them like 20 minutes
to send a [ __ ] email
yeah yeah i um
i think that the system is completely
broken one way to make like immediate
meaningful change would be that but it's
the same people it's like it's like
asking the police to investigate
themselves they're going to find no
wrong doing every time senate and
congress in general is not going to
change the laws so that they themselves
will all get fired you know what i think
it's something we need to start talking
about and stop being afraid to talk
about because it's it's like a huge
[ __ ] problem yeah look at this air
traffic controllers mandatory retirement
age 56
that's a good age to stop congress i
think yes well i honestly if it was up
to me i'd say like 65 that's generous
you know
60. 60.
i'm trying to be generous right because
like i do think that
you can be highly confident but that
won't that's not a silver bullet like
that's not the solution the solution is
still obviously like that the system is
designed in a way to churn out these
exact same results that you're seeing
and and you know every facet of our
existence basically normalizes the
struggle the suppression that you
experience
um this is just one of the things that
like directly hits you in the face that
hypocrisy watching congress go on
vacation immediately after like a
[ __ ] shooting
shooting right watching them go on
vacation watching them uh completely
unable to
come to a a
serious uh come to find a serious
solution for any of the underlying
issues that they uh run campaigns only
giving themselves raises while the
you know all republicans are talking
about not wanting to raise the democrats
do some democrats as well right and and
the first part the thing that pisses me
off the most is like
they're all they go on vacation no
exception they're like yo it's vacation
bro like the government could literally
shutting down no budget approved it
happened and then they go on vacation
for two weeks it's like [ __ ] dude
work yeah
yeah no they are uh
cops and and politicians
are like
two
jobs where you have no performance
indicator like you can just be a
gigantic [ __ ] failure and still get
your salary
not do what you're supposed to do and
still completely just you know ride the
wave
of of being in that position of power
um do the wrong thing all the time and
get rewarded for it it doesn't exist
like if you are a fry cook
okay you fail as much as or you you uh
operate like a congress person you're
getting fired three days ago
yeah
that's it and then nancy pelosi you know
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] psycho she is i
hate her guts i mean i i do too she's
all just the insider trading thing i
mean she's like they go well they're
trying to pass a bill to ban uh
members of congress and
significant others from trading in the
stock market which is [ __ ] great
except for nancy pelosi as everyone know
her husband is the most successful
trader of all time somehow for example
he just bought like a bunch of uh nvidia
yeah
right before they gave a huge [ __ ]
grant
yeah right before the champions
legislation
bro twenty thousand shares of a video i
think it was like around
six million it's so [ __ ] important
and then they asked her recently like
what do you think about uh this uh
prohibiting members of congress from
trading she's like well we need to be
able to propose particularly
how about you [ __ ] participate in
dying of old age so someone could
replace you
yeah
um up to 5 million worth of chip maker
stock ahead of semiconductor bill vote
[ __ ] you so
blatant
to me like the argument of being like
well we're a capitalist country and like
our family members should participate in
capitals i'm like no
no you shouldn't you're like you're
you're in a position of profound
privilege man if you want to [ __ ]
prove it yeah prove you have skin in the
game and be like all right i'm going to
put it in a [ __ ] blind trust you know
prove that you're [ __ ] in congress
for the right reasons you should not be
given the opportunity
for all straight up blind trust for all
uh politicians it's just like ridiculous
totally
um
it's been more than six months since
member of this committee proposed
measures to put an end to inappropriate
financial transactions despite these
efforts speaker pelosi and her husband
remain
undeterred from cashing in their stocks
by the way to continue on this
interesting journey here
members of the state department
aka
diplomats 65
mandatory retirement
federal law enforcement national park
and firefighters the department does do
some you know clandestine operations and
whatnot you got to have your wits about
you if you're gonna
if you're going to engage in like
espionage or soft power not be president
taking out shinzo abe but that's what i
mean
yeah
that's a young man's game that's a young
man's game yes
[ __ ]
park rangers have to retire at 57 dude
yeah i mean it's it's the same as
anything it's it's the same exact like i
said cops and politicians like you need
significantly more training to become a
hairdresser than you do to become a
[ __ ] cop like how does that work you
know what i mean
this is interesting florida supreme
court justices according to florida
constitution shout out florida i guess
for something
mandatory retirement age of 70. uh
michigan judges of all levels could not
run for election past the age of 70.
yeah although there is a precedent for
this stuff all the judge stuff was
surprising me when we were researching
because obviously let's do that with the
supreme court like adam
like like how old are those yeah age
capped that [ __ ] i'm so on board with
that how old are those [ __ ] or
i present i present a trade offer you
become a all-powerful
uh appointed unaccountable deity that
has full control over what happens in
american life but then you have to be
assassinated by the end of your by the
end of
eight years
okay yeah put some [ __ ] you know have
some skin in the game you know what i
mean it's like oh you want to be a
supreme court justice okay well then at
the end of your term you know we launch
you uh into space
his name the ronald reagan assassin john
hinckley john hinckley comes for you no
but he's a failure on that front
unfortunately we'll train he doesn't
have the right stuff we'll give him
we'll give him proper training like
in like an intricate
almost comical uh way they have to get
like assassinated by the end of their
term we put a term limit on it maybe put
them in like uh like a trebuchet and
like launch them into a volcano
yeah
no i don't want to do that to mexico
yeah why would you that's poor mexico
they've already let's teach them about
them them walls
make our dead supreme court justices
michigan judges of all age cannot run
for
election after 70 minnesota has a
statute establishing mandatory
retirement age
for all judges at age 70. somebody still
seems too high i agree but at least but
at least there is a cap yeah and there's
a big difference between 70 and [ __ ]
75s you know 80.
uh new hampshire constitution says
all judges have to retire by age 70.
i see 70 a lot supreme new jersey
supreme court 70 maryland constitution
uh for judges of 70 oregon
mandatory retirement by 75 i mean that's
pushing it but at least it's there
see the age thing the reason why i said
it's not like a foolproof system the age
thing is something that like the
republicans have already
uh the republicans have already factored
in that's why uh kavanaugh is 57 amy
barrett is 50.
neil gorsuch is 54.
um and and katanji brown jackson is 51.
part of the reason why like these are
lifetime appointments so
what uh the federalist society wants to
do is put young spry people in there
that are not going to [ __ ] die off
under a democratic administration i mean
how old was uh ruth
ginsburg when she passed
um
billion she had cancer like 700 times
too so that's another
fact
excluding like the new appointees that
are all it was 87 87 80 [ __ ] seven
87. it came in such a shock when she
passed yeah
so young she clinged to power so
desperately that she resulted in brett
kavanaugh becoming a [ __ ] justice
yeah that's some real girl boss [ __ ]
sweaty you don't understand real sorry
bro i mean good for all the [ __ ] you did
but why the [ __ ] didn't you why didn't
you know she sucks 87 [ __ ] she's
terrible
okay whatever i don't i honestly don't
know anything about her 27 years
um on supreme court but at least she did
give us
87 man most legendary trump moments of
all time yeah i love that one let's
watch
i miss him he's coming back with the
music in the background no
is that
candle in the wind wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait
wait tiny dancing i need to answer yeah
we i don't want to get claimed she just
like is it on here this is c-span
yeah they probably got claimed what wait
no i think it actually was playing in
the background
yeah i liked his music i was like these
fan why are you memen no it's like so
funny though
[Applause]
what she just died
oh my god i didn't know that i didn't
know that i uh
i didn't know that you guys stopped you
guys stopped
i didn't know that wow i didn't know
that it was actually heartfelt
yeah no because he was stoked are you
kidding me he was like oh [ __ ] yes dude
god damn she was like big man upstairs i
got you the
tiny dancer was playing in the
background yeah didn't add that like it
was just there it's one of those perfect
moments in politics it's just so great
if you exclude
the young spry folks that donald trump
just uh
put up there
so ginsburg was 87.
here we go clarence is [ __ ] 74.
roberts is 67. alito72
soda ma meyer is is 68.
62 is kagan
um
i'm [ __ ] done with these old
[ __ ] dude
but remember age is not the only
factor here notice look notice that age
is not the only factor here because they
are still
some of the most reactionary people in
the supreme court right now are the
youngest right amy kovet barrett is
literally 50 years old younger than even
katanji brown jackson shout out right so
it's just uh it it's it's a
significantly more complicated system
you can have young
foot soldiers for your cause
um
of course you can yeah so the system
needs to be fundamentally altered a life
a mechanism of change and we currently
do not have it because it's been
neutered over the over the course of
many many years the labor movement has
been eviscerated in this country bro i
can't believe ginsberg was
87. that's nancy pelosi she was a babe
for sure oh that was nancy pelosi yeah
yeah that is right there is nancy pelosi
the jfk party but just ill like he tried
to [ __ ] her for sure
i mean no
i didn't want to say that i didn't want
to put that on her you know but i'm just
saying jfk tried what he was he was a
dog jfk was a dog oh i got a dog in him
that dude [ __ ] anything that moved man
yeah and nancy posey's is cute she's
definitely cute
i don't know you could tell she looked
good in her young age even now she's got
some milkers bro let me see the milkers
oh god okay i was gonna say i don't know
if we talk i forgot if we talked about
it or not but the picture of her on the
beach
no i don't think we ever did that's safe
enough
for youtube
i don't know i'm just kidding
that's pretty impressive man for uh
i've talked so much about this i can't
even i've just
also i mean this picture has a permanent
residence in my mind okay
i love that face
you should show the full photo because
her hands are
what is like the indication if you have
hands that look like that you should no
longer be in office
i'm in love
uh vin diesel's a fan
his standards are pretty low i mean
about anyone
let me see them hands
oh my god it's done it's a wrap gee geez
you know your veins on that mother
it's just like
i should probably that's that happens
when you don't have circulation i think
i forget what it's called maybe she's on
human
growth hormone yeah just like you that's
why the milkers are so just like elon is
going in one place
but you know
i despise her so much she just sucks so
bad
i love when people say like don't
sexualize nancy pelosi it's like don't
object to financial policy no no don't
worry like she's a demon regardless of
uh you know anything else
um
and interestingly in other countries
south korea for example
it's common practice among firms in
korea
to set mandatory uh retirement age of
60 or well below
it's the norm in fact recommended
by the government aged employment
promotion act
retirement for south koreans in this age
group is rarely voluntary
and many are not financially prepared to
leave their jobs oh well that sucks yeah
in fact almost 60 percent of retirees
hope for re-employment well that's a
[ __ ] tragic feeling of society i
don't like it when um
cia client states uh that we planted
especially with like dictatorships
originally uh have a
have have better amenities for their
citizens than we do here in america it's
like how are you gonna how are you gonna
allow other countries that you are
dramatically changing the outcomes of uh
have a better
have a better society but even though in
korea there's you know a lot of hyper
dystopian capital sounds like a lot of
the people forcing retirement actually
aren't prepared for it there
yeah that was uh that was my reading on
it and this is a uh
it's a big problem too you know and as
well apparently um a lot of people are
forced to retire there and i think it
the
the
the pension thing is less of an issue in
japan as it is in south korea but yeah
in south korea
uh a lot of the elderly um wind up very
destitute because they're just can't
find employment that's horrific and you
know that that's like that's another
problem but you know i have no problem
with old people being in the workforce
but there's like high
high competency required jobs
that they hold on to and these people
are generally have enough money to
retire because they've been in high
competency high reward
jobs for long enough and they just
refuse to pass the torch now this is a
separate conversation from
people
elderly people who cannot afford to
retire and have to stay no
they deserve a life of dignity they
deserve a life of dignity and that is an
abject failure of the again hyper
capitalist korean government
uh not doing the right thing refusing to
do the right thing and taking care of
the elderly when they're no longer of a
productive age
um it's it's just
that's where you see some of the most
like uh
that's where you see some of the the
most glaring failures
of our current economic organization is
like the way we treat
the the unproductive
right like if you're not a par if you're
not a part of the productive workforce
all of a sudden you're cast aside and
you you are forced into like uh
poverty
um that's that's just ridiculous i do
think that uh making sure that uh the
old people the elderly are taken care of
is is incredibly important i do think
that they should also have
you know activities like keeping keeping
all people you know busy is good
as a chance to offset alzheimer's
um
so i i'm i definitely think that you
know you could make work for them but
yes competency driven
fields of work they should not be
working in yeah don't don't get confused
i mean i want
you know
safety nets and support for the elderly
this is a different topic but brendan
fowler asked i wonder what tate's
cam girl retirement plan looks like
that's a good question what are the laws
like in romania i wonder
yeah i don't
i don't know how you get out of it but i
do know how you stay in it sometimes
they'll take your passports away and
refuse to let you out of the house
love that yeah how would you look into
that by the way speaking also retirement
age is 61 in romania by the way
interesting 61. 61.
oh those mills the milfs are being
i mean prosecuted block era uh countries
usually have like way higher rates of
home ownership uh
it's just like there are some remnants
of the ussr that unironically benefit
their current existence
if this is real play it right [ __ ] it no
it's not it's not man
god damn it i wanted it to be real
that is the most like oh my god that
chair holy [ __ ] that is the most mana
chair you can own
i won't even notice that oh wow yeah
yeah that's a that's a that's a grandma
throw my grandmother my great-grandma
had that exact same thing i'm pretty
sure
my aunt had that chair yeah straight up
hey hassan don't get freaked out but
this is your future oh no
don't panic it's over he's just he just
destroyed me and he destroyed me and
he's coming after him your competition
is look at my chat saying roll rolled
all he needs is some pearls
he's got him yeah yeah you put the
pearls on and it's over
damn it's over for me we don't have much
time left we're based the show's
basically over but speaking of
alzheimer's that crazy ass story broke
about like 20 years of alzheimer's
research was based on fabricated
research did you hear yeah i i heard
about it but i haven't looked into it um
it's super [ __ ] up yeah so there was
like a landmark
study in alzheimer's treatment 20 years
ago
that all research has been based on and
99 of the treatments developed for
alzheimer's doesn't work and they're
just like how do we treat this illness
now they just found out that that was
completely falsified billions if not
trillions of dollars and 20 years wasted
on a disease that could could very well
have been [ __ ] cured or greatly
assisted by now it's so [ __ ] up sad
and tragic people that falsify studies
are definitely going to hell
and um and it is hopeful in a way though
because
hopefully it means that we can
get on the right path now
to curing one of the most horrific
diseases that affects a lot of
old people
and and actually even younger people
sometimes doing tragic early onset
i just
the other day speaking of alzheimer's i
wonder if this is connected or maybe not
because they're so isolated but that it
was announced that cuba had developed
like
a breakthrough on uh alzheimer's
treatment they already have a lung
cancer vaccine right um
what there's like amazing like medical
why don't we exotic like
they feared lung cancer yeah cuba has a
lung cancer vaccine does it work
it's for it's for a specific type of
lung cancer it's not all lung cancer but
for the type of lung cancer that it
works for it's like apparently
incredibly effective so why is cuba
developing cutting-edge medicines and
what do you mean this is that's
unironically the reason why cuba is able
to uh send doctors all over around the
country or all around the world
uh whenever people need it during like
you know natural disasters or whatnot
and the reason why they have this is
because like
i mean americans who are fed uh
spoon-fed a lot of like anti-cuba
reactionary propaganda are immediately
gonna say well they're doing it for like
you know promo they're doing it so that
people say okay well the proof's in the
pudding [ __ ] make the [ __ ] fact
you're my lung cancer bro i'm moving to
cuba yeah there are i mean there's
articles written about this cuba has a
lung cancer vaccine many u.s patients
can't get it without breaking the law
like this oh like that's gonna [ __ ]
stop me yeah i mean he's like kidding me
yeah i love that
[ __ ]
pigs yeah demon monsters but that's not
surprising
they spend a lot of money they spend a
lot of their resources which are already
incredibly limited as a consequence of
the inhumane blockade that they've been
subjected to but the largest imperial
power on the [ __ ] planet ever since
they had the audacity to overthrow
batista a incredibly brutal incredibly
violent dictator that the american
government at the time was funneling
resources and weapons into
okay
um by the way shouts out i mean this was
the cuban revolution happened what uh i
think two days ago uh many many years
ago so shame all the [ __ ] with cuba i
mean it's a beautiful country it's so
close to be such a great
place for so many americans to visit
yeah july 26 uh 1953 is the date of uh
of the cuban uh revolution so you know
well you know what go on shouts out to
castro
here it says allegations oh yeah fat
yeah
so i just hope
in a sense that um
i took the gum out of my mouth by the
way i'm not quite as good as hassan is
i was trying my best to proud of you
well you didn't shut up my lip and stuff
but i just hope that uh
we can get on the right path with the
alzheimer's treatment yeah uh
interesting specifically before i
to get older right
the fact that a country that has been
brutalized
so severely by the largest imperial
superpower on the [ __ ] planet on its
backyard okay
is still able to funnel some of its
resources it's already limited resources
into
groundbreaking cancer research and
treatment
is 100 percent proof
that america has the capability
if it were to move away from a
profit-seeking system in healthcare to
literally truly solve so many medical
complications but unfortunately
profit is significantly more important
than actually curing people
and that is the reality like this
[ __ ] tiny island is able to do [ __ ]
like this
uh with with with the with the
horrifying hand that they've been dealt
despite the major blockade despite uh
all the inhumane things that america has
done to cuba they've been able to do
such a thing
it's ridiculous
but it is a shame on america for you
know both the blockade and also on top
of that not
focusing their resources on on these
sorts of uh
on this source uh this kind of research
uh we stand cuba here in this studio
morgan hill said i work in clinical
research and we had the casava study i
guess that's the one that was falsified
right it's sad that this happened
because we were hoping to really help
people with alzheimer's
yeah so like you said it sounds like
horrifying yeah going down the wrong
path for decades because of this i read
an anecdote where someone was like my
uh
grand for my mother had uh alzheimer's
and they were asking about the medicine
that they have
and he's like i can prescribe you more
but it doesn't do anything is that crazy
in this day and age we can't treat that
[ __ ]
it's wild yeah well let's go people
let's get on the right path come on now
and whoever's falsified that is burning
in l for sure
seventh circle man
an eighth circle
we make a new circle just for them it's
one of the saddest diseases you don't
really
realize how you know how deep it is
until someone you know goes through it
it's really tough horrible on both sides
the for the family and the person yeah
my grandmother my grandmother passed
away this year from alzheimer's like she
had it for almost eight years it's it's
horrifying it's really really horrible
yeah you know
i'm sorry to hear that yeah sorry about
that
uh but uh
let's get there guys
and uh so anyway basically we're saying
uh you know
what are we let's read summary so [ __ ]
old people kind of
like a specific small group of old
people right stan uh everyone else
uh pelosi's got milkers which you know
is dope but
but but she's used them for evil yes
i don't know
i'm just trying to tie it back to the
narrative here that's great i mean the
biggest takeaway is [ __ ] what is up
news nation yeah
i can't wait to get more videos so
friday let's have some updates room okay
guys okay gotta keep tabs on our boy
here
love that firm
anyways thanks for watching everybody
this has been leftovers from our
80 billion dollar compound oh yeah
thanks for watching guys we'll see you
tomorrow friday real quick our saudi
prince just gifted 50 sub oh shout out
or uh 50 members members go up our
numbers
or sorry benefactor there's one guy in
the chat who's always like 50. is he
saudi he's not it's just a joke no we
just joked he he's donated like
thousands probably i don't know 1500 or
even more uh it's probably yeah it's
over a thousand we call them oilers
in twitch on twitter spoilers oh yeah
yeah yeah anyway shout out to our oiler
[Laughter]
and uh we'll see you guys tomorrow at
uh the regular time
for after dark we have a guest tomorrow
oh yeah
yeah you're right so it's not a normal
episode but we have whitney cummings
coming tomorrow that's right so that
should be fun nice
thank you guys
and also shout out to the big brother
fans out there we stand them too we
gotta root for them whatever their name
whatever their names you guys
taylor and turner taylor turner and
hooch
burner and a huge favorite hooch baby
taylor turner win one for the good guys
[Applause]
all right thanks for watching everybody
peace
okay now let's do like this
so anyway
[Music]
you